we're going to hear later on today what
happened in shrewsbury but you know the
headline is lots of babies died when
they didn't need to
yes i think it's going to be a very
sobering morning i commissioned this
report back in 2016 when
two families came to see me and they
were worried about the circumstances
surrounding the death of
their children and um i'm afraid it
mushroomed having started investigating
the complaints from 23 families
uh don ockendon ended up looking at
nearly 2 000 cases but one thing i would
say kay it's very important i was
listening to your interview just now
with dominic raab
the nhs facilitates the birth of nearly
600 000 babies every year the vast
majority are totally safe
and indeed they're getting safer
but i think today's report is going to
be a very sobering read
yeah we saw what happened in
mid-staffordshire and that was of course
under a previous government's watch um
you were in charge weren't you when we
saw what happened in shropshire
learning from experience what can we
learn about what why we didn't learn the
lessons of what happened i know slightly
different circumstances but the bottom
line is that life is a life is a life
absolutely i mean
baby deaths have come down by about a
third over the last decade
but we're still
27th out of 38 oecd countries when it
comes to infant mortality so
countries like hungaria and slovenia
do better than us
and i think from i haven't seen the
report but i think what we'll see is
that staffing is very important my
select committee said we needed 2 000
more midwives and 500 more doctors
today unfortunately the government is
going to vote down an amendment to the
health bill
which would mean that we always trained
enough doctors and nurses for the future
which is very very disappointing but
staffing is one another is this
so-called natural births ideology
which put pressure on mothers to avoid
c-sections
even when that might have been the safer
option and i think that is something
which uh thankfully the nhs has now
removed all targets associated with
reducing c-sections
but trojan healthy was one of the trusts
which had the lowest one of the lowest
c-section rates in the nhs
and the third thing is the blame culture
um i mean even in this inquiry
uh donna ockendon believes that doctors
nurses midwives were pressurized not to
be open with her
and told there could be professional
reprisals if they were and
too often in the nhs it's difficult for
doctors and nurses to speak out it's the
thing they really want to do to learn
from the stakes but we make it too hard
it's a fourth point funding as well uh
given the first part of the ochenton uh
report which was published last year as
you know an extra at 95 million pounds i
believe was made available by nhs
england uh in funding for maternity care
there wasn't enough money available
there's always pressures on funding in
all health systems because of the aging
population now of course the pandemic
pressures but i think if you ask people
in the nhs today they would say that
staffing shortfalls is a bigger issue
sometimes they have the money to pay for
doctors nurses midwives but they can't
find the people to actually do the roles
and that is because over very many years
we haven't been training enough doctors
and nurses i set up five new medical
schools but even that may not have been
enough
and that's why i think we need to have a
long-term overhaul of our workforce
planning because it takes so long to
train people up and you you can't just
do it overnight and overseas stuff being
prevented from coming into the country
uh by a conservative government
well there is an nhs visa
so
it shouldn't be the case that anyone is
prevented from coming in but i think the
truth is that immigration and getting
doctors from overseas was always a get
out of jail card for the nhs over very
many years but now with the pandemic we
have a two million shortage of doctors
around the world a 15 million shortage
of nurses
and we've got to be honest and say we're
we're a proper health system we should
be training the number of doctors and
nurses we need and frankly is it ethical
for us to be recruiting so many doctors
from much poorer countries where they
are often desperately needed at home
would you test yourself on friday um
after the lateral flows are no longer
available if you had a cough or a cold
well i would um
i understand why um the government says
we have to get back to normal um all i
would say is that we just need to keep a
weather eye on all of this because
you know we have got a big spike in
infections at the moment it doesn't look
like it's translating into people being
seriously ill we have got to get back to
normal at some stage
uh but we need to be prepared to change
course very quickly if the situation
changes if we had a new variant for
example i think the lesson of the
pandemic
is that you have to be willing to change
course quickly if the facts on the
ground change
so are you telling people at home that
they should test themselves if they have
the symptoms of a cough or of a cold or
flu
yes we should and you know that's the
same as you know taking your temperature
if you think you might have flu i mean
we have
got a lot of covered around it can be
very dangerous indeed particularly to
people who aren't vaccinated
but we are going to have to move you
know given the billions of pounds that
the testing program is costing i mean
i'm someone who's criticized aspects of
the government's response to the
pandemic but i do recognize we have got
to move to
some type of normality so um it's a
difficult judgment as to when that
happens and i would just say if the
situation changes
we might need to look again at that
decision
what about those people that can't
afford to buy the tests
well i hope we will find ways to make
sure that they are able to access the
tests they need
okay talk to me about partygate before i
let you go basically um the first
tranche of fines are in 20
separate fines we don't know if it's 20
separate people what we do know is that
there was a culture a dining street
where people were breaking the law when
we were in the midst of that lockdown
that you were just talking about what's
your interpretation of what should
happen next
well i think it's very serious the whole
thing um but i think we don't yet know
the full facts um there is an
investigation going on you know we don't
know whether the prime minister himself
is going to be asked to pay a fine we
don't know the full subare report and
i'm not saying that to sort of
dodge your questions on it okay but i
just think that it is this is a legal
situation and so for people like me to
make a judgment on for example the prime
minister's role i think we do have to
know
whether the police think that he has
broken the law or not and we don't yet
know that no i'm not i think
no i know you're not but i'm just but
you know these are very serious issues
and i
like all mps i've got a lot of
constituents who are very very angry
about them
yeah my question i suppose is about the
culture
at the very heart very top of government
where at just the first tranche we've
seen that the law was broken on 20
separate occasions at the very heart of
government
and that is wrong and i don't think we
can defend that i think we can
understand the pressures that people
were under in downing street in the
middle of that national emergency
working all the hours that god gives but
we can't defend breaking the rules that
they set for everyone else no we can't
okay good to talk to you can i hear one
of your little ones in the background
there you can indeed i'm about to cycle
her to school
okay good i better let you do that then
thank you very much indeed for joining
us thank you
thank you